[Musique]
un concert étrange des notes qui
s'entrechoquent et dans les couloirs
l'impression que les fantômes de
rachmaninoff et sa bande surveille de
près les 400 élèves du conservatoire
russe de paris
derrière ses portes dans le 16e
arrondissement
des poupées russes
des jeunes violonistes
les saxophonistes
des concertistes et des danseuses et une
seule méthode pour tous la méthode rue
ce qu'on enseigne dès l'âge de 3 ans
ici on danse on chante on apprend le
russe est bien sûr on le parle ligne
et qui dit école dit directeur ici c'est
un conte le comte chéri métier et il
dirige ce conservatoire depuis 26 ans
c'est un conservatoire entièrement russe
c'est un conservatoire qui qui est le
prolongement
du de la société musicale impériale
russe de saint pétersbourg
le compte était un descendant direct de
cette ligne est impérial son laguiole en
toute simplicité c'est le dernier tsar
nicolas ii au poste de directeur
monsieur le comte a succédé à de
nombreux autres tous russes blancs
artistes installés en france après avoir
fui la révolution bolchévique de 1917 à
paris ils ont voulu recréer la société
musicale de sa majesté
tout ça ce sont des des sommités de la
musique là vous avez un portrait
magnifique de rachmaninoff qui est notre
idole je dirais puisque c'est sous son
nom que nous continuons à travailler
on l'aura compris de 7 à 77 ans au
conservatoire on vénère davantage
rachmaninoff que lady gaga ici les
jeunes pianistes s'entraîne pour des
concours internationaux il recherche une
technique particulière reconnue dans le
monde entier la méthode rachmaninoff
explications avec la russe elena kron
professeur de piano il mérite
par exemple on joue mozart
on utilise très très
beaucoup de technique de doigts quand on
joue les pièces rachmaninov au québec
on a besoin
[Musique]
tour utiliser toutes trois
dans la matinée c'est l'arrivée de
madame la directrice ou madame la
comtesse elle n'est pas russe et dans
l'enceinte du conservatoire elle préfère
qu'on l'appelle par son nom de jeune
fille huguette bultel peut-être que j'ai
plus de liberté quand je suis adulte
elle parce que je serais un petit peu
j'aurais tendance par exemple
aller dans des endroits un petit peu
canaille en ré sandwich une bière alors
quand on conteste le fait pas voilà le
programme du viet le mercredi après midi
c'est l'accueil de tout son petit monde
d'enseignement et russes mais les élèves
de toutes nationalités français
américains japonais et italiens
brésiliens est plutôt de familles aisées
serge gainsbourg lui-même d'origine
russe il y avait mis ses enfants
réputation
international et c'est un pour les gens
c'est un devoir un mythe de pouvoir
venir ici
et d'avoir un diplôme d'honneur de
conservatoire sera créé aujourd'hui si
seulement 25 % des élèves sont russes
c'est aussi parce que la communauté
russe de france s'est réduite comme une
peau de chagrin de 3,5 milles au début
du 20e siècle elle est passée à cinq
mille aujourd'hui katia tchenko
comédienne célèbre est aussi passé par
la section danse classique dames et
régions veulent travailler plusieurs
années
ça coûte importante et élève
ses preuves celle où et qui a grandi il
ya une chose qui me que j'avais même
retenu de la méthode russe c'est que
quand on danse on doit toujours raconter
une histoire on doit toujours
dégager une émotion par rapport à cette
musique sur laquelle on danse ne pas
uniquement faire 1 2 et 3 et 4 voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est ça c'est ça
serait dommage à l'heure du déjeuner une
seule adresse la cantine russe du
conservatoire ouverte à tous au menu
tarama bini mais pour monsieur le
directeur ce sera du boersch c'est une
pioche ou parfois il ya du de l'avion
mais si on accompagne le borj avec des
pires auch qui soit aux choux soit
l'avion
monsieur le comte lui parle mange russe
mais si depuis la chute du mur l'ex urss
à renouer avec ces ruses blanc elle ne
l'est pas pour autant à financer son
conservatoire
aussi devraient être fiers que nous
soyons après 90 ans nous soyons toujours
là que nous soyons toujours
déterminé à défendre la culture russe et
des traditions russes la russie devrait
comprendre qu'elle doit nous aider
espérons pour monsieur le comte qui
après l'année de la russie en france
lamy medvedev va réviser sa copie allez
pour se consoler une petite vodka
services dans des kalachnikov mais c'est
du jus de cerise
nous nous connaissions monsieur
kalachnikov
l'inventeur
merveilleux
il est pauvre quand vous pensez les
millions de kalachnikovs qui ont été
vendus dans le monde non non il a eu
juste accroît la décoration de je ne
sais pas le nom de lénine et voilà vous
pensez qu'on vit avec une décoration